[Applaudissements]
quelles sont les limites à la perfection
professionnels quand on m'a proposé ce
thème
j'ai éprouvé un paradoxe
paradoxe entre résonance émotionnelle et
contradictions intellectuelle résonance
émotionnelle
ça m'a renvoyé à recherche de plénitude
d'accomplissement de vibrations
contradictions intellectuelle mon
cerveau là tout de suite perçu comme une
demande de recherche d'objectifs de
normes qualitatives alors en fonction de
qui nous sommes nous vibrons tout ça
extrêmement différemment limitée
perfection sont deux termes emprunt
d'intensité ils vont puiser des
références personnelles très intime
pour moi la limite c est une ligne rouge
une frontière à ne pas dépasser ce
risque de tomber dans le chaos
la perfection c'est l'art c'est la
beauté c'est le sensible c'est la danse
et la musique
mais ça c'est mon vécu sais qui je suis
encore une fois chacun dans notre
unicité nous vibrons ces termes très
différemment en fonction de notre
éducation de notre héritage et cela
c'est très important de tenir compte de
cette diversité
alors si je devais reformuler cette
question en assumant qui je suis je
dirai comment se réaliser
professionnellement à une plénitude tout
en se réalisant personnellement comment
faire que le monde ait conscience de la
valeur de nos actes fournier qui nous
sommes ni notre équilibre
alors pour ne pas faire durer le
suspense sachez que je n'ai pas la
solution
le prisme que j'ai choisi de prendre
aujourd'hui c'est d'assumer de vous
parler de mon vécu mon expérience sur ce
chemin on pourrait déverser disserter
philosopher des heures et des heures sur
les raisons qui nous poussent en
fonction de notre profil à cette quête
de perfection quête de perfection qui
peut nous amener à l'épuisement parfois
pierre j'ai moi même été un très bon
petit soldat
j'ai cherché longtemps dans le regard
des autres une forme de reconnaissance
c'est important pour moi alors je me
suis épuisé dans des actions
quantifiable mesurable tangible je me
suis beaucoup épuisée mais en fait j'ai
envie de prendre une autre direction
parce que je crois qu'on vit une époque
extraordinaire
on vit une époque formidable
elle est extrêmement anxiogènes ses
vannes mais la vérité c'est qu'elle est
vivante enthousiasmante inspirante
énergétique
c'est une époque pétri de paradoxes de
clivage le fastt verse le sio hyper
technologie versus des retours primaire
à la nature en véganisme et outranciers
lorient l'occident et puis cette hyper
connectivité qui nous rappelle sans
cesse les réfugiés perdu en mer le
terrorisme les crises économiques les
catastrophes climatiques incessantes
permanente et paradoxe encore
l'injonction bonheur l'injonction à une
vie parfaite et cette vie parfaite en
plus on la limite nuit parfaite c'est
une carrière flamboyante argent
notoriété une vie de famille une vie
sociale épanouie sont évidemment postés
sur les réseaux sociaux
la manne funès la happiness la pleine
santé le sport il ya quand même de quoi
faire sacrément des crises d'angoissé
il assume complètement d'en avoir fait
et puis la vie faisant l'âge avançant
j'ai réalisé que cette époque
extraordinaire nous offrait en fait
l'opportunité de lâcher prise
cette époque si on le choisit elle nous
offre le cadeau de reconnecter à la
plénitude
alors voilà pour lâcher prise pour
reconnecter à la plénitude pour ne plus
avoir d'attentes
j'ai besoin d'un camp de base est plutôt
que d'être omnibulé par des montres à la
société que je vais avoir une bonne note
dans son reinking de l'échelle de la
réussite
j'ai choisi de me reconnecter à moi-même
et la vraie question c'est qui suivent
mais pour de vrai pas qu'ils doivent
être pour que mes parents mes amis mes
profs mes collègues mes collaborateurs
mes boss mon conjoint m'accepte soient
fiers de moi
qui suis-je quel est mon degré de
conscience sur le sujet et une fois que
j'en ai conscience
est-ce que je suis ok avec être cette
personne alors c'est évidemment ultra
violent de se regarder en face
c'est extrêmement complexe de faire ce
chemin vers la vérité
et puis de ne pas juger alors ce qui est
génial quand on fait ça c'est que sur un
malentendu on peut commencer à s'aimer
et là on réalise que ce qu'on croyait
être nos plus grandes failles sont en
fait nos plus belles sources d'audace et
on appréhende la vie très différemment
parce qu'on a plus peur parce qu'on a
plus rien à prouver et donc pour
reconnecter à ce camp de base
j'ai juste accepter ma part de
médiocrité car il ya un autre grand
scoop
nous sommes tous des êtres exceptionnels
est médiocre
alors plutôt que de me lancer dans une
quête du graal
j'ai choisi des actions simples tangible
factuel
sinon on s'auto saborde avant même
d'avoir commencé il y a eu l' écriture
il ya eu la reconnexion encore il ya eu
des cadres et méditatif il ya eu la
musique l'écriture
j'ai écrit des pages et des pages les
tonnes de pâte en fait l'important ce
n'est pas tant ce qu'on écrit
l'important c'est de relire a posteriori
ce qu'on aurait pu coucher sur le papier
de manière complètement instinctive et
primitive la reconnexion encore j'ai
choisi de me tourner vers des
expériences corporels pour arrêter
d'être systématiquement dans ma tête
alors j'ai choisi la course parce que
c'est simple c'est facile d'accès ça ne
nécessite pas particulièrement de
contraintes horaires et après chaque
course je réalisais que ce qui était des
problèmes se résolvait les peurs
infondées disparaissait et surtout géré
connecté à mon corps j'ai repris
conscience de mon enveloppe corporelle
géré connecté à mon souffle
encore une fois la vie est bien faite
un accident du genou a fait que j'ai dû
trouver et diversifiée mais pratique
sportive et me tourner vers des
activités plus douce de là à dire que
cet accident de ski m'avait juste fait
prendre conscience que je ne
m'autorisais pas la douceur
il n'y a qu'un pas alors un peu par
obligation avec un genou en vrac et
beaucoup d'à priori
je me suis tourné vers le yoga je pense
à rencontrer des mangeuses de graines un
peu évaporée la vérité c'est que j'ai
embrassé une pratique d'alignement
spirituelle et corporelle
ma vision de la spiritualité elle est
très simple je crois foncièrement que
nos croyances nos convictions les nôtres
ne peuvent se construire que sur la base
de nos expériences et pas sur la base
des expériences des autres ou sur la
base de la lecture de bouquins écrits
par des autres c'est extrêmement
important de vivre ces expériences
parce qu'on se les approprient alors en
parlant d'expérience
une expérience très importante pour moi
c'est la musique la musique me permet de
reconnecter en profondeur à mes
sentiments
elle me permet vraiment de plonger dans
mes émotions ça je crois sincèrement
qu'il faut tout assumer on vit dans une
société en occident où c'est pas bien en
fait les sentiments et moi je crois
qu'il faut absolument pas avoir compte
par la honte d'être amoureux par baron
d'être triste pas avoir honte d'être en
colère pas ma ronde être heureux il faut
pas avoir honte d'avoir envie de rire il
faut pas avoir honte de culpabiliser il
faut pas avoir honte d'avoir envie de
faire la fête
en fait il faut tout assumer et puis il
faut y aller franchement
alors voilà la musique ça même à ça même
ça m'aide à assumer pleinement tout ça
parce que toutes ces émotions
finalement c'est ce que nous sommes
alors voilà j'ai beau travailler dans
une grande banque et faire des trucs
super à la mode
la vérité c'est que ce qui m'a
reconnecter à la vie c'est des choses
extrêmement simple j'ai juste repris le
temps de comprendre que j'avais mis de
côté les choses prioritaires même pas
prioritaire vital à apprendre à respirer
écouter mon corps
apprendre à poser un cadre de calme
quand il s'agit de mener une réflexion
importante pour moi
bref j'ai juste reconnecter à ce que
j'appelle mon un tiers un tiers un tiers
faire ma tête entière mon coeur et mon
âme un tiers mon corps alors avec
beaucoup d'humilité j'essaie de mettre
en place une hygiène de vie qui me
permettent d'accorder un temps mieux
répartie à ces trois tiers et qu'on ne
se trompe pas de combat
je ne prône absolument pas les
différents grande manif ou non
de bien-être de pleine conscience je
suis absolument pas légitime à le faire
et puis objectivement c'est pas du tout
ma came
moi j'adore sortir dans l'apéro je tombe
très régulièrement dans plein d'excès le
vrai sujet c'est qu'à un moment il faut
quand même avoir l'honnêteté d'assumer
que personne aucune personne physique ou
morale n'est responsable de nos
problèmes
personne n'est responsable de notre
épuisement la vérité c'est que le seul
responsable de ce qui nous arrive c'est
nous et notre seul ennemi c'est l'ego
alors légaux c'est une petite couche nos
ses yeux entre vos trois tiers et votre
capacité à incarner qui vous êtes votre
vérité lego c'est un poison qui
s'immisce et qui vous empêche d'être
lego vous fait adopter des comportements
des propos qui font que vous renvoyer au
monde l'image de quelqu'un que vous
n'êtes pas vraiment alors certes ce sont
des habitudes des choix facile des
conditionnements pour autant est-ce bien
raisonnable de devenir un personnage de
série télévisée malheureusement souvent
bas de gamme alors voilà
moi j'aimerais faire un don simple
aujourd'hui encore une fois avec
beaucoup d'humilité
je voudrais juste rappeler à ceux qui
ont envie de l'entendre que s'il le
souhaite il ya toujours une initiative
qui est de se choisir soit se choisir
soi c'est pas et gothique se choisir
soit si je veux dire les autres faire
attention à soi apprendre à devenir
qu'il en est le dire au monde
ça lui faire un cadeau alors pour ceux
qui le souhaitent dans les jours qui
viennent
achetez vous un joli notebook en papier
recyclé un stylo noir c'est important le
silo noir pas bleue pas verte pas rouge
noir et puis écrivez écrivez tout ce qui
vous passe par la tête avec beaucoup de
frénésie sans vous restreindre nas ou
vice et aucun sentiment aucune sensation
aucune émotion
mettez tout sur le papier car commencé à
assumer ses sentiments ses commence à
être alors soyez merci
[Applaudissements]